injustice - as a brand new story mode
and we've got every single cutscene for
you here all in one place you can use
the timestamps below to jump some
specific chapters and also use the
annotations at the end of the video to
choose your own ending or you can use
the links in the description so grab
some popcorn leave a like on the video
and enjoy the show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
mother Cara come quickly
[Music]
stay with me pop the champagne
our boat that he's gone millions of
people that's only the beginning
Brainiac to stabilize the planets core
Krypton won't hold together much longer
while your research another something
you can do that's why we're here we
should that's what you've been working
on your uncle's your eldest double a
planet that can sustain Kryptonian far
away from you
he's built a ship just like this for
your cousin cow cow it's just a baby
which is why you will need to protect
him teach him our wave be teaching what
about you no no I won't leave you please
please don't make me I can't come with
you but you'll never be alone you belong
to the house of el Camas a house of hope
never forget that
never
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in my years fighting crime I've learned
one truth and every villain is the hero
of his own story
Superman was no exception The Joker
drugged him tricked him into killing his
pregnant wife Lois and made him trigger
the bomb that neut metropolis so when
Superman killed the Joker I understood
why we all did but once that line was
crossed there was no going back
he gave himself and the Justice League a
new mandate stop all crime before it
happened by any means necessary but he
couldn't see his good intentions were
leading him down a path of tyranny and
evil that's our greatest hero became our
greatest threat the one esteem is full
of criminals at Arkham they're the worst
of the worst he's going to kill them
Davian sounds like justice to me killing
people isn't justice Superman can't see
that he's grieving he needs time to heal
yeah and what if it had been Gotham if
Joker had killed me
your own son thought you'd say that
not responding we're being taken to the
back page prepare to eject
[Music]
[Music]
a warning shot cyborg I won't hurt you
unless I have to you're going to have to
my friends were in the tropics Batman
stopped by a beef boy gone we do this
that never happened again you're running
to be angry but it's not a blank check
and the Justice League isn't a death
squad you don't see it yet
but Superman's wrong your glider skills
need work
yeah I'm fine thanks for asking let's go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so you won't kill but you're fine with
traumatic brain injuries secure the
loading docks here to help yes to keep
you in Clark from making a terrible
mistake
none of us wanted this but the Joker
forced our hand
metropolis changed the world now we have
to change with it not like this
of all people I thought you would
understand
I need you to tell me the truth where is
he
cellblock C you can't turn your back on
him he needs you
that's why I came doc what are you gonna
do this where we going I don't know
where tell you tell me what's happening
get back in love
now
[Music]
two minutes
[Music]
you're better than this Clark these
inmates are irredeemable they're thieves
rapists murderers like the Joker that's
the problem with fighting for truth and
justice the battle never ends and
executing the will ended first Joker now
this when does it stop when there's no
more crime when people can live without
fear we want the same thing Bruce I
wanted to kill my parents murderer I
could have but that's not the life they
wanted for me and it's not the life Lois
would one for you don't you put that on
me
a red solar Draenei to dull your powers
you need to stop take time to grieve
before it's too late
you wouldn't you're supposed to be my
friend which is why I have to stop you
I'm sorry Clark get awake me look who I
found six bad psychopath
how many women ever killed 121 121 huh
sounds incorrigible to me Robin let him
go
you'd rather fight your friends than the
real problem I'm warning you son son you
didn't raise me the League of Assassins
problem solved
who's next dammit Damien
this is a line we do not cross oops
then stay on your side Batman I'll be on
Superman Indiana I I never meant you you
coward we're at war with these animals
you think you're better than him you let
the Joker keep on killing you couldn't
say blow it or Jason or anyone that's
enough let's go
but the inmates not today
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's been years since the regime fedil
Superman's behind bars
Dameon my own son is there with him but
we can't ever forget why we put them
there we must stay vigilant
I thought your goal was to reassure
people mr. Wayne you're not alone in
rebuilding Gotham and metropolis but if
we don't change some minds soon thought
that's why you hired that overpaid PR
firm Lucius convincing folks to move
back to these cities is a lot harder
when they're afraid someone's going to
knock them down again Superman is never
getting out I made that clear
what Wonder Woman black Adam Aquaman
they're still out there somewhere and
seemingly immune to prosecution I know
you built brother I to keep tabs on all
those loose ends but the public doesn't
know brother eyes secrecy is critical
our enemies can't fight something they
don't know exists well then at least
follow one bit of advice we pay those PR
people so much money for what's that be
a little less Batman a little more
billionaire playboy get out around town
in the daylight and smile focus groups
show people feel safer when they see you
smile hmm that would be your other job
Bruce consider widening your circle of
trust
nobody wins all by themselves not even
you
as a reception area this place needs a
lot of work Dinah Oliver thanks for
coming on short notice you're lucky we
found a sitter
[Music]
my great-grandfather built the original
Gotham underground but these days it's
the Batcave
and this is brother I
more like the Eye of Sauron surveillance
hub more than that a communications hub
linking every satellite and server on
the planet it warns us when trouble is
coming and guides us when troubles here
must take a real genius to operate I
don't know about genius but I just got a
PhD
[Music]
dinah dinah sabe you shook him a long
way a world away but the change of
scenery is nice I was surprised you
called Ruth
things seemed to be going well so what's
up dismantling the regime created gaps
in global security we're covering them
where we can
but we're stretched thin vulnerable
Harleen show them what you found right
I'll bet
gorilla grodd everyone's favorite
talking ape he's got himself a band of
bozos called them to society my mole in
gorilla City says garage planning
something big but what where when we
don't know one thing we do know
scarecrows gonna shift Grodd a buttload
of be a guest from a hideout in
slaughter slump very miss Kay deli
good thing I packed my bug spray I need
you three to stop that gas before it
gets to Grodd not joining us for the
party unfortunately I can't leave Gotham
without worrying the public don't worry
bet with this crew on the job what could
go wrong I know I'm the new guy but you
really trust Harley she's a different
person since Joker died mostly
can they move any faster
the only grande taking my head off cuz
your boys are too slow they're not dead
shot will be ready for tomorrow's attack
tomorrow fancy meeting you here
keep them moving I'll see what that's
about
good I seen you in forever you here to
take down these punks
[Music]
quite a catch stylee red go with death
your man Bru's was supposed to better
care for the green all he's done is
remodeled the concrete jungles of Gotham
roughly where I said there's not much
difference between him and Superman oh
you're a few cones short of a pine if
you think your new friends care about
the green rod will keep its promises or
he'll be my next victim
Oh red why are you making me do this
[Music]
here girl we could team up again drive
all the boys crazy you know like the old
days the old days were fun but these
days I'm all wasting so much sweep up is
for you thanks your fears please I stuff
up this stuff a chick that you'll
appreciate
lera hide homes but everyone has
something to fear instant
[Music]
[Music]
ah darling
look at you such a big girl cosplaying a
superhero lobby in the back King but you
hear it what real you very none of the
floorboards
stretch stretch scratching to get out so
when you cut her friends throats
and laugh about
[Applause]
my girl
Oh Holly always such a disappointment
why do I bother angels like cellar with
a cheap sueded tape of gran telling me
who I am
ever I guess Massa was the planet time
but now that of a Mista J Lina corner
let's all before bankers away
[Music]
I heard your dad I thought plant life
over as long as it nears wait Elena
you want to wash we're the good guys
good I care for that but I do care my
[Music]
mama always said I had a black thumb now
you're ready to be all ears
it's scarecrow it is Kunz you want then
mixing toxic gas right in your backyard
we came to stop them
they return I will be ready
laughing you are amazing it's everyone
on the team we love Tanya a would
consider that should our interests live
for now though the swamps
[Music]
where were you just in the clouds
listening if someone saw you how many
times have we told you it's too
dangerous outside conduct I spent
decades lost in space suck in hypersleep
until atoms on my ship and now I'm
cooped up here how can we make you more
comfortable let me out
Tana you've taught me what my powers can
do this world needs help
Earth's people are so divided they're
always fighting that's the world without
kal-el Batman has eyes everywhere he
can't know about you before we're ready
I'm not afraid of some guy in a mask oh
I can then steal with my bare hands
so could your cousin well what good are
these powers if I can't even help kal-el
we will Cara just like you and I free
Diana from the mesquita the time will
come we'll save kal-el and Batman will
answer to us
our best chance to stop the ride is a
preemptive strike
sounds more military than vigilante you
try calling the army
there is no army not yet to break up the
regime we had to start from the ground
up
so what us three extradite Grodd from
under his entire guerrilla army
grodd's their alpha take him down and
the others will submit but be wary of
running into other members of his
society they're more coordinated than we
knew next up gorilla city guess I better
call the sitter mommy and daddy are
coming home late if this is more than
you and Olli are comfortable with Dyna
all that Blue Beetle and firestorm take
over no we can do this you've been out
of the fight a long time you have a
family your family too Bruce I couldn't
be there to finish the fight against
Superman I'm damn sure finishing this
one
[Music]
[Music]
gorilla City our time has come in a few
short hours we break the yoke of
oppression forever
no more regime no more Justice League
today the world welcomes its new masters
Society
today we show the world that we are
superior today we bring anyone who would
dare stand against us to
low self-esteem not that guy's problem
that's a lot more than a few society
members it's all him
they're headed indoors out of sight from
the soldier Harley keep the jet one when
we signal bail us out they know a little
kick cross you hire Superman
speechwriter soldiers must be properly
motivated to sacrifice their lives carry
hate the perennial motivator better not
turn that hate on us or the society is
over as long as we have a common agenda
Captain Cold
you have nothing to fear you mean as
long as we follow your orders reporte
just ready to move out
good god now we'll tell the others
cheetah cold you're the first word we
already lost a shipment it's slaughter
swamp hope your silent partner is still
deliver
maybe it's time you filled the identity
of our silent partner
since we're relying so much on him or
her
she makes his presence known from the
earth a few words from the brave in the
bowl I'm the brave one right I'm not
bald enough to disagree with the several
tours of slaughter Schwalb I presume
Pandavas I call first did go pin the
luchador
no idea what you're doing
sure I do I think or olicity fighting a
lady in a cat suit this is one for the
bucket list there I can die happy
so everything's under control
one of us needs to distract him while
the other kids with - oh it's Benham -
Tony how kind of Batman sending his
underlings come enjoy returning you to
him in body bag
I'll distract him you take snipping dude
your spine will break like glass now
you're done
that was my favorite arrow birdie now
[Applause]
now where's that damn dirty ape
I come to you as darkness falls
dr. fate Dinah Lance Oliver Queen
in the past I feel that you've endanger
but a grave crisis looms that I do not
know if I can stop it
me broad and company we've got that
covered broad is the part of a much
greater master a new order is coming aya
first you leave with me now what I can
still save you if that's the case we're
staying here
Batman will need our help everyone and
everything you know will die I will
Shepherd you to safety
lest you suffer the same fate but forms
if necessary the good doctors been
wearing that home for too long let's
help him out watch my back you should
not have returned to that band you are
not fated to fight his battle well like
a good friend once told me screw fate
I'm not abandoning Batman
Kent you okay your headgear really had
you going I lost control of the brew the
spirit of the helm
thanks to you I'm back in charge for now
I have to consult my masters the Lords
of order pray they'll intervene before
it's too late
too late for what Kent what's going down
the most magic bars me from saying more
I had changed fate too many times this
planet's destiny is no longer clear what
comes next
near mortals cannot stop for better or
worse your vacant rests in the God's
hands
that was spooky yeah come on let's find
Grodd and get the hell out of here
you've overstayed your welcome we're
happy to check out but you're coming
with us
firing a talking ape wasn't enough and
to throwing telekinesis give us a song
Sookie savage Pete
I forgot to bring my banana arrow wait
you eat bananas right or is that an
offensive stereotype
I was just trying to be PC
surprised that work let's call it a day
and get Harley out of here it's never
good when you slap the cuffs on and then
they start chuckling shooting you for
this better but you've already lost
[Music]
Holly I uh I got nothing you victory
over gorilla grodd warrants for the
study green-skinned smart money's on
alien uh-huh Martian like John John's my
point of origin was a thousand light
years removed from Mars on the planet
colu
I am
stop please cause and effect resistance
begets violence and we will resist
please justa you're the grave crisis we
were warned about what do you want I
seek the one you call Superman for years
I believed I had destroyed Krypton and
all its witness
Superman's survival recent oversights I
must correct
Superman's no friend of ours I am aware
but your planet has also piqued my
interest
it's many contradictions are fascinating
we'll never serve you sir I am a petty
death but I collect worlds
preserving their essential knowledge to
enhance my intellect and then I discard
the remnants why
your species thousands precious metals
arbitrary symbols of status
I value technology and like your metal
trinkets knowledge is more valuable when
it is rare
[Music]
brother I give me an update on the team
at gorilla City
I can act in that Bruce Wayne of Earth
why not
I can Brainiac you cannot retain control
over the past days brother I has been
absorbed into my neural network it is
now an extension of my mind you a
fragile human captured and imprisoned a
fully developed male Kryptonian maybe
I'm not so fragile to prevail you
harnessed advanced sciences nano
technology satellite communications
interdimensional transits I am taking
these tools from you why the Kryptonian
belongs to me and soon so what your
plant
great Hera where else beside metropolis
Gotham Beijing Moscow so many cities all
at once
cuca
who is it we need to get tell now
[Music]
[Music]
you
you're wearing a suit am I in trouble
again
Brainiac what can you tell me
how do you know that name you're afraid
of him he's invading he says you belong
to him
Brainiac killed my Mara blew up Krypton
you never mentioned that before how do I
beat him you can't not without me I'll
find a way this is my fight Bruce you
need me
neither hand dr. Randall I don't know
Barry sat links out internet and phone
are down maybe this old ham can help us
you fitting in okay people trading you
all let's just say people here on
thrilled to live in close quarters with
the flash convicted regime criminal
pardoned regime criminal
give it time welcome on lwb are you
there w bass
how fast can get to Metropolis my pardon
agreement was pretty clear on no powers
do you think that matters when aliens
are invading you help tear down the
regime Barry that's why mr. Wayne asked
me to take you on and if Batman thinks
you earned a second chance who are you
to argue
[Music]
as predicted Barry Allen has returned to
action the trust forces ready girl enjoy
this
[Music]
nice aim Deadshot she's gonna choke drop
that me ain't healing super fast
absolute zero
for God's sake Colt look around
ya crazy day kind of like when Superman
with nuts and you went right along with
palmistry later we have to help these
innocent people the same innocent people
who cheered Superman when he executed my
friends my sister I'm sorry Colt but you
never hurt civilians you're better than
that
once upon a time I was
yes we both let each other down thanks
Kitty I was helping you as Bruce's mole
for all the good it did Grob never
trusted me enough to share the whole
alien invasion plan we've gotta help
Diana Ali
we will first we need to get back to
Gotham if there's anything left of it
the time it'll do that to you what's
with you autumn you should be fighting
this invasion got no choice
crowd burn and look suppose in my head
is powerfully trigger whether I like it
or not I got a coupons dirty work
I know it's just business crowd said you
could resist a good crisis you'll barf
on you don't belong here and miss the
return of Barry Allen
[Music]
[Music]
we're in a long way from the future to
hurt you Barry
but this timeline is all wrong so go
back to your own time reverse-flash
think I haven't tried your regime buddy
killed one of my ancestors now I'm
trapped in a paradox I can never go home
please like hurt you don't know how many
more reunions I can take guess I could
come back later
how now not today
nice to see you too Barry who's dead
hand you pry that ring from you know it
doesn't work that way
ring chose me even after you bailed on
the Guardians to join the Sinestro Corps
a Guardians locked me up but they also
trained me to overcome my fears I earned
a second chance
they gave me Guardians made a mistake
you were holding back weren't you I told
you I'm trying to make things right I
betrayed my core my planet and my
friends that's the worst part all day
I've been reminded how I failed to be a
hero how hard it's going to be to redeem
people's trust yes we're both on that
path we have a long way to go very to be
a lot easier if we're together
[Music]
we need help don't we
not his you gave me a second chance
because you got your head straight and
helped take down Clark if he was still
in charge he'd still be wearing yellow
I'm not that guy anymore
look I get why you don't trust me but
you should trust the Guardians this ring
means something they put me through hell
to get it back fine I've got my orders
just thought it'd help weak watery
Lantern maybe it's time I widened my
circle of trust what can I do you're
going to Atlantis our circle of trust
needs
Aquaman and his Marines you think he'll
help he's been off radar since the
regime fell he didn't like getting roped
into the regime by Superman sure won't
be happy to see me get used to them
[Music]
Batman wants my Marines to fight his
battle like the time Superman ordered me
to invade metropolis we were all on the
wrong side of that war but next time my
peoples blood is spilled it will be for
Atlantis not the surface work you're one
of us to Arthur your father my father
was human but my duty is to Atlantis I
don't trust you Jordan you or any
surface dweller now leave and remind
Batman stay out of my seeds and when
that's on your doorstep Atlantis will
defend itself maybe sooner than you
think
we need to help each other go I don't
need your distraction
I'm not leaving need I remind you whose
kingdom this is listen to reason Arthur
I'm sorry I I didn't come here to fight
you
this is exactly what happened up there
first they take out communications then
I am say
they're your oceans but it's also my
sector let me help you
[Music]
cover me
[Music]
[Music]
hmm I thought the only Redeemer down
here to torture would be Aquaman cheater
let's not beat around the bush Wonder
Woman's in hiding maybe down here tell
me where's your Amazon friend
didn't you hear i unfriended her so did
Atlantis nyah I don't need a golden
lasso to make you tell the truth
[Music]
Bad Kitty
[Music]
my people are getting flanked hold this
line your rear guard on it and you i'm
the vanguard how jordan you have
returned good to be back where I belong
and I like you in a prison cell
even as yellow lantern you never showed
me the proper respect but I will show
you how easily your will be spoken
break this we're locking down the gays
when the fights not over pal sorry I was
somewhere else
where's this leave us you put yourself
at risk for Atlantis maybe you can be
trusted so you're in I can't
I belong here defending my people
Oh George Red Lanterns
Atrocitus and text are agents of
vengeance power five rage don't worry
I'll handle these - ring - ring good
luck
you've been messing with my head haven't
you Atrocitus Sinestro yellow Landon
Robin Williams victims demand vengeance
you may have cast out their ring but you
are not of souls you're not the first
person to tell me that Dexter would tear
your I'm not your blood but I sent you
of a higher calling a spark growing
within you a spark of rage
what are you doing Perez this is Tiger
you may have overcome your fears but you
still betrayed the Green Lantern's hurt
your allies how could you ever forgive
yourself I can't
[Music]
Oh
in game in like it's night to become
vengeance during the Red Lanterns don't
evil shall escape my sight let those who
worship evils might beware my power
Green Lantern's light
you're right I do hate myself for what
I've done but my will is stronger than
my hate your world is burning when it is
ashes you will burn for vengeance
guardians don't need to know about that
one
the beta phase is complete Earth's
defenses irreversibly compromised begin
all the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I circled the globe larger ships are
being positioned over these major cities
even with Aquaman's Marines we're still
badly outnumbered of the plan we have
one right we have to evacuate the
occupied cities before taking on
Brainiac but we need firepower any heavy
hitters on the Luthor Wayne payroll only
Blue Beetle and firestorm but they're
busy too busy for this they're the last
line of defense
Brainiac moves on Superman well if
Brainiac doesn't try busting him out of
prison Black Adam and Wonder Woman will
the worst things get more people will
think we should let them out to help
them I'm just saying hope the new kids
can hold down the most wanted man in a
galaxy beetle and firestorm are free but
together they're the most powerful team
we have
for real Jaime Batman does not think are
important
aliens are reading and drunk our duty
guarding Superman Ames cronies who
already have guards rearguard guards
really does Jason you need to step back
take in the bigger picture rather be in
here than out there
this suits an alien war machine and your
guys's firestorm matrix we could take on
Brainiac and boom accidentally blow up
the world Jaime's right
we haven't mastered these powers yet
listen to yourself you do
we're badasses and badasses belong on
the front line this is the front line
Brainiac running amok is a crisis
Brainiac and Superman both that's an
apocalypse so we're the only thing
between crisis and apocalypse yeah I can
get behind that
brilliantly for the Superman fan either
way I suggest we use
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
redstone self secured must be the power
center the power center if it goes down
those generators shut off and he flies
right out of here
[Music]
[Music]
am I dreaming
[Music]
you
[Music]
here's the plan one of us pays Adam the
other restarts degenerates before
Superman can prove even command more
likely you would die
guess we're on frontline
you're a naive boy with too much power
much like this it's really fast
maybe I really am a badass let's go go
back lock down Superman's oh no man
standards have dropped you losers Oh
gasps but to impress Batman why he's
weak if you're Baba's weak what's that
make you
I take after my mother
I'll see if this mofo so a left
hope I never had a kid like you I was
the perfect chives
that wasn't fit to be mine
you should respect funny Wonder Woman's
outside keep them what's left to the
gods busy if it wasn't her who let you
out I
Cara
[Music]
another Kryptonian you recognize me care
my parents stored your image on my shoot
you're my protector sorry I'm here
decades late you and I left Krypton at
the same time but the explosion threw my
ship of course way of course you haven't
aged a day
hypersleep while you were growing up
that was aa night I never thought I'd
see family again someone with my eyes my
own blood
you knew my parents they loved you so
much
Layana needs a hand cyborg how long give
you five more minutes then it's lights
out I don't want to leave you I'll be
here
injustice or between even she is not out
of army that is your constant Kryptonian
tapping come on Batman
tell me
[Music]
got a hand Alma these people's
cryptography is legit doesn't mean I
won't break
[Music]
what's your milking time
[Music]
the red Sun generators read to
reactivate that console before Superman
powers up amateur hours over rookies I
want cyborg how was the family you're at
QB for the four tight you had a cannon
army do that never thought I'd be a
prison guard
QV that was a long time ago I'm not your
prisoner
nobody's cheering for you now brainiacs
too much for Batman I'm your only chance
here's the thing Superman Batman asked
us for help
he didn't draft us make us sign a
loyalty oath or threatened us with jail
he won't go far enough that's why you'll
feel Kryptonian huh the professor knows
how to do you
you're spraying kal-el like it or not
look for partners we need cows health
care you have no idea what Brainiac can
do no but I know what Superman can do
if you belong here - what did I tell you
we got game professor nice crab - Wonder
Woman and feet of Steel you fought
valiantly but this battles over you
won't be - what a professor but that's
crazy
maybe we can control but no other option
get out of here I mean it's a great
location you're in a new book it's the
only way now go leave all of you you'll
get a hell of a lot worse than sunburn
resolve problems rather than let
Superman go
birth
firestorm stand down
[Music]
who are you Superman's overprotective
cousins you keep so many secrets but you
can't stand it when once kept from you
okay
you can't be pretty actress you're right
Diana I can't
[Music]
[Music]
you're ready to stop Brainiac by any
means necessary by the means at hand
what's your game
they're always three moves ahead saving
the world is enough for now I never
going back in that cell we'll cross that
bridge later right now the world needs
us
[Music]
is only where there have been surprising
developments kal-el is freaky but more
remarkably he is not the last Kryptonian
there is another refugees can we please
continuous plan kal-el is not yet at
full strength but remember the
Kryptonians belong to me thanks to
flashes recon we have locations for
every ship in brainiacs sleek
they're targeting major cities on every
continent made of give us some privacy
list Batman about the prison we that was
reckless don't pull a stunt like that
again make up for it by finishing
another mission discreetly we have to
evacuate these cities before attacking
the fleet but we need communications
restore first so before we get started
cyborgs going to fix brother I I am not
that tech support that's not the issue
Victor
[Music]
[Music]
cara saw firsthand how Brainiac
destroyed Krypton she says we have less
than 48 hours before he does the same to
work without tight coordination
we'll lose valuable time and that means
we think brother I Catwoman and Harley
will join you you'll need their help
getting into the Batcave just give me
the coordinates I'll open a portal and
boom too big
you can't i reverse-engineered your
armors mother box technology try
teleport into the Batcave set a boom
you'll go splat so how do we get in the
old underground there's a tunnel
entrance under Arkham I'm taking you to
to Arkham Asylum promise it won't be
awkward nothing I need a few hours in
the solarium but the portraits of
Solitude assuming you haven't torn it
down not yet Damian Adam you're with me
and the rest of us we can't just sit
here we plan our attack once brother
eyes online we mobilize
remember out there there's no regime not
anymore so we do not kill
[Music]
let's go you're with me
why'd you keep it keep what
[Music]
hmm forgot that was there
[Music]
[Music]
this way Pharaoh
Harlan you okay sweet sweet this time
you'll be a good girl for Mama meeny
miny Harley needs a girl talk sorry
Harley I'll try not to leave a scar I'd
be sure did a number on you
your girlfriend's a real maneater Arkham
gave us so many memories
Selena bewitching guards late-night
poker mandatory shock therapy oh that's
right you were spared thanks to you a
billionaire boy toy I didn't ask for
special treatment the hell with this
pity party you're just dying to hurt me
aren't you Tin Man it won't bring back
what you lost
especially below the waist
poor Harley smell the wrong roses and
now she's going in shock
bye-bye baby doll we can't just leave
her
I'm gonna mow you down Oh cyborg but we
don't have to fight let's kiss and make
up I prefer women who are insane
you got a defibrillator in there yeah
use it
Carly
people find diamond all we want to get
to Brainiac seriously they're already
dead why you got to say that Brainiac
collects the best and discards the rest
Black Canary and arrow definitely not
the best I take them over you only de
victor here we are
wait here Harley make sure no one
followed us after you please
[Music]
[Music]
- quiet
Bogey's and then not bad
I told Ron you were loyal to the batch
he called me in paranoid elisee listen
when I said Batman would not relinquish
his cave so easily soon
not just this place but all of Gotham
will be mine I've got business of thing
of all the ways to torment the Box
hurting you is one of my favorites
yet you've never broken me was that fun
for you as it was for me ready to meet
brother I about damn time systems still
running brother I need the clean power
source something Brainiac can't touch
the cave got backup generators that
you're doing
they dressed on a pinnacle of human
evolution someone has a secret admirer
with real humanity individual attention
you must produce interesting thought
there's one problem I'm a team player
and humanity that's my team
what you are capable so much
[Music]
[Applause]
great online
I know vas memory and Internet liberated
from the weaknesses of flesh and emotion
apparently liberated from my good looks
and charm - we need that backup power
now
so degree if mirror matches with the you
as it is to me
for years I dwelled as a subroutine
within your system and anomaly I never
found in existence outside you now I
realize my perfection and your
obsolescence
not so perfect after all backup powers
on let's get this party started
well [ __ ] not even you can gain control
of life now try to just teach a brother
I north
this minor subscribe last drop of you
[Music]
the brother mine is online welcome back
thank you miss Kyle Victor stone Ian
things'll trade the back to the best
system override authorization LK for D
for system administrators Selina Kyle
retinal verification required I think
Dean confirmed standing down brother I
bring geosync comms online fruit the
comms are your brother I broadcast on
the old Justice League man broadcasting
we're back online everyone we have one
hour to evacuate civilians whom you
engage Brainiac and asleep
[Music]
where should we start
Stannis we don't have much time
Batman strategy is all wrong delaying or
offensive is pointless
it's one less hour before Brainiac sent
us all to Hades saving these people
could doom billions more I can hear the
people down there
all of them seriously like I was on
Krypton when I didn't have these powers
and look at us and I just think we can
give them hope
you
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
why are they so afraid welcome back
Diana
[Applause]
[Music]
your heart still cold let's put you on
AI nice Roberto give up your code of
honor snark why lower yourself to work
withdraw you're not so pure Amazon you
do execute a golden glider she was my
sister a sister you led into a life of
crime she paid for your mistakes my
condolences
[Music]
eobard thawne right Perry said you're
some kind of time traveler yeah and let
me tell you about the future you think
you're immortal but in my time Diana
you're quite dead
and Oracle you are not Diana you're safe
thank Rao we have to find car keys we
will Clark we don't have time for please
I missed you
we can beat them kal Brainiac Batman
they both go down today and will rule
side by side as equals and lovers
I turn to you when Louis died you took
advantage manipulated my grief turned me
into someone I wasn't meant to be that's
not true my love made you stronger is
that what you tell yourself that's what
Superman told me scarecrow you're not
afraid of Superman you're afraid you
corrupted him brave hero your worst fear
is becoming a villain of the story Hades
with your mind games
classic anger displacement we should
continue your therapy this therapy
sessions over
girl of Steel you are rare a mind
no wonder Brainiac wants you dead or
alive Kryptonians are vulnerable and
we've closed cut like masks
hang in there car the gods will protect
us I'm surprised someone so feral still
follows grodd's orders no princess
I only joined law to drive my own quarry
you a full Baron like when you start a
God's power but found the cheetah skirt
more like the Cheetahs gift I'm stronger
factor and you want blood your curse can
never be undone this service you deserve
Yeah right Fonzie take time
she's had enough Wonder Bread this isn't
your business clown you heard that no
killing
you lecture me how much blood is on your
ledger Quinn Oh buckets full honey I was
trying too hard to impress the wrong guy
kind of like you with Superman another
thing too much blood
he's gonna hurt a lot even better what
do you think you're doing Cara stopping
you before you make a mistake that
lunatic deserves to die maybe but she's
defenseless she's had no trial you told
me Amazon [ __ ] with honor
I trusted you Diana you're gonna be okay
I'll get you to a doctor
Cal can protect you simple man Oh
blondie you're funny
did you find anything I analyzed the
Kryptonian data like you asked you
didn't miss anything they just didn't
have an answer for Brainiac there has to
be something a blind-spot a weakness
brute force won't be enough if your
powers are restored I should leave for
Conda make sure its defenses of
repairing Brainiac hasn't attacked yet
the rock of eternity is magic I'd
conduct from prying eyes even brainiacs
but I don't expect him to be fooled
forever
kal We Need to Talk
give me a minute both of you Damian told
me what happened is Diana all right
she's fine but she was gonna kill Harley
I've never seen her so cold-blooded yes
it's unfortunate I know how is she
thinking it's unfortunate Diana chose
now the deal with Harley more infor
jannat that you got in a way what the
Joker's sick and Carly's mind beyond
healing when she relapses innocent
people will die innocent people are
dying now she was helping us don't be
naive
Cara Harley's a criminal my only mistake
was not dealing with her sooner Diana
said the Joker was executed were you the
one who I took one life to save millions
but it wasn't just one cow was it how
many how many everywhere I go people are
afraid of it now I know why it's not how
I wanted things but
humans they've been slaughtering each
other for millennia I stopped that
violence humans need strong leadership
we have to save them from themselves are
you your health or General Zod
don't let Carly before hold on Cara
realizing maybe your father locked you
up for good reason Superman's before of
a father that fat man could ever be cows
should be setting a better example you
would submit Care authority ever since
you found me everything you told me
half-truths lies to cover up your own
evil you see the world as a child does
good and evil are not constants their
meaning defined by those with power
lucky for you I find power and restraint
Cara please listen to me with our powers
we can't hold back or the ones we love
pay the price I'm sorry I wasn't here I
couldn't help you
but metropolis wasn't your fault I
promised myself never again this isn't
who we are the house of El isn't ruled
by fear Hulk isn't enough to save the
world without me they'd be dead
[Music]
I can help you think about all you've
lost Carl what if you could have saved
Krypton I think about it every day
that's standard Brainiac
he's extracting the city thoroughly then
we fight it back
I must go to protect contact go we're
heading to Metropolis what about her all
that matters now is stopping Brainiac
but when this is over you need to choose
your either with me or against
[Music]
[Music]
why can't I stop this why won't you let
me fight back
how could there be order at fraidy a
Quinn's tails
and order
[Applause]
Superman and Supergirl are almost here
the others are tackling complete
shouldn't we be in Gotham
Brainiac controls the entire fleet from
that skull ship take him down take them
all down contact dead ahead
[Music]
[Music]
they came open blocking on the
scholarship
[Music]
five seconds to impact prepare to eject
three seconds you're welcome what just
happened
brainiacs force field is creating a
concussive feedback loop so the harder
we hit it the harder it hit
[Music]
[Music]
you
the proton rules are incapacitated
completely extraction
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the force shield concentrate this energy
at your point of attack move faster than
it can and you might break through
[Music]
created letting sufficient decrease
yield refreshing to put the tentacles
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
I couldn't find his body
yeah there's heartbeat I was supposed to
protect him from this from you know he's
gone I'm sure that's the best news
you've heard all day I'll miss him too
you mean that he was a good friend
possum I trusted him with my life but
the Joker got to him and I wasn't there
to stop it I lost my friend Clark
I've missed him ever since
Atlantis gone didn't listen now we all
died together
no one's giving up yet anyone here from
beetle or firestorm this is your fault
booth
Cal and I would have beaten that you
should have followed our lead Diana
millions of people are trapped on that
ship we have to save them
not no longer humans have yet to expand
their civilization beyond the confines
of this tiny planet did you call
ingesting lovely like betas are taking
position all across the planet
if not our they will explode in use
burning the Earth's atmosphere rendering
this world a better the less you spend
her clothes or else she is pretty close
found survivor my last opportunity to
study the effect a Yellow Sun of
Kryptonian cells surrender her and I
will spare this work even if I thought
you'd honor that deal we wouldn't take
it
you have one more to reconsider thanks
for giving a new girl a chance maybe I
should go No
we'll find a way to take down Brainiac
shields we have to we could try shorting
them out but we need to generate an
insane amount of power perhaps science
is not the answer so we might be
vulnerable to a magic based attack I can
drive the immense magical power from the
rock of eternity to the gateway in
conduct but I need an order a medium to
channel it something that can withstand
the power how about the Trident of
Atlantis yes that could work we get the
shield down then what
cyborg said Brainiac controls the ship
with his stop but I did cut him off from
brother I it's possible I could make a
signal disrupter that blocks his neural
network if you get brainiacs shields
down we can disarm the beta bombs then
that's our plan Aquaman
I don't get to Konya
[Music]
but also eternity you see this in a
fourth-dimensional I refrain promoting
the gayborhood
to accessory exhibition because it would
draw his I mean like once the door is
opened it's only a matter of time before
Brainiac attacks a fight I look forward
to ancient ones unveil the Gordon path
to me in your name's sue Haru come on
the Hokey
Black Adam has revealed conducts power
and its location the society will obtain
a sample of the rock of eternity for me
I wish to study Earth's so-called magic
the society is disbanded before
Earth will be bears to conquer the
foolish to destroy and yograj Earth can
go 12 I serve Brainiac as usual I will
give you new soldiers bring me that
sample before the earth is destroyed and
your loyalty will be rewarded
[Music]
that's why quickly don't bother
there's no time
instructorship is on its way
conduct will be brain acts music calms
broad foam can achieve great victories
if you are willing to sacrifice them
[Music]
this king isn't easily captured here
comes the cavalry getting it you to die
together the last of mankind's monarchs
what kind of ruler sacrifices his own
people for brainian my loyalty is
Rainier or gorilla City which to myself
I'll wait until that alien exposes his
weakness and kill him with his ship I
will be unstoppable
I've had my feel of God sorry
your hubris will be your undoing it
isn't hubris when one is truly
exceptional
exceptional is not the word I use
Looby we thought you were dead
scarabs hard to kill Batman told me you
guys needed a hand considering your
sidekick comment all
[Music]
[Music]
how does this work exactly
we imbue your Trident with a spark of
the rocks power it's full light is
released it will seek out your weapon
your thoughts will guide the Wizards
power violent I am ready
[Music]
Hey what are you doing a sleeper agent
to lead you here despite the power is
sterile before was easily manipulated
this honor is wasted on a child when
we're finished I'll tear the scarify his
body and make it flowers my own a king
Grodd you're a brute our true leader
senses people you only serve your scent
reversed
you hurt my people Grodd in their name I
will have justice not the day to test my
resolve
[Music]
people matches demand justice
[Music]
Oh Roger head empty so not much has
changed very arrow out of the wine
[Music]
kazar
the
[Music]
cyborg where's that signal disrupter
coming at you all you have to do is hit
the trigger but it only jams a local
area you need to get within arm's reach
of Brainiac good
[Music]
[Music]
they did she'll sit down
supergirl on me Victor help the others
fight those beta
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the signal gets stronger this way what
is it
millions of them
[Applause]
so many languages the Kryptonians
kandar peugeot city home we have to help
them
I'm not sure we can
there has to be a way
[Music]
[Music]
Laura's all round until recently I have
bought my collection of Krypton to be
complete your charger will make itself
you have failed in every effort to
oppose me you are not exceptional merely
an ordinary specimen of primitive
species just lost of him
[Music]
[Music]
I thought I could make an entrance
where's Cara captured somewhere on board
we'll find her but we only have 20
minutes before brainiacs betas scorched
the earth why aren't the others here
they're attacking the betas just in case
we don't go through we will
[Music]
firestorm what happened to you
you think is your walking bomb how do we
get past wanting to the power gf master
device store matrix all knowledge will
be subsumed contagious connection to
answer your question this is how we get
touched it a battering against of
quantum vortex hold on
and young cat that control rod perfect
for stopping runaway vision
we'll get your minds right I promise
you have a plan it's a work in progress
I might be able to restore them that's
new brainiacs adapting quantity or
difficulty difficulty as a digital copy
it won't be real Oh
chirps poor and once that's Brainiac
talking time to get him out of your head
[Music]
the green needs it's real Guardians
it should disrupt their link with
Brainiac firestorms brain patterns are
changing can't read what's happening to
swamp them Jason professor Stein yeah
yeah we're both here what happened
Brainiac added a third mine to your head
like we needed that Brainiac [ __ ]
firestorm we'll get you back on terra
firma report to how he'll need help
fighting brainiacs suicide data sounds
like a job for firestorm good luck
no Brainiac where is he
I don't know
the ship's walls are lined with left
Bruce Wayne of Earth kal-el of Krypton
your battles echo across the universe
your war has had consequences on the
other of you could foresee the chaos you
spread is a cancer upon the cosmos
only Brainiac can establish order I'll
deal with it you hate magic
I'll manage and island Albania
I've always respected big but Brainiac
can't destroy my home not again your
misdeeds precipitated his arrival on
this planet brainiacs curiosity was
piqued by your decimation of the Green
Lantern Corps now he comes to spare
humanity from the chaos you unleashed
I'll carve out my own destiny
the Lords of order their voices are gone
it's over Kent I'm sorry for attacking
the helm commanded me they can't command
you anymore both of you have defied fate
accorded chaos but down to see you
working together again you must keep
order or the Lords will impose it if not
through Brainiac
[Music]
even a magical beard like dr. fate
recognizes my superior arms in time the
entire universe will adhere to my design
unless we stop you I offer nothing less
than deliverance your environment is
poisoned your civilization has exhausted
its resources the Earth's decline cannot
be reversed we'll find a way we always
do
[Music]
Earth's time is up
where's cars being vivisected she has
already taught me much about the nature
of your powers allow me to give you a
proper demonstration I Met Your
Strengths you cannot match my intellect
you are only a Kryptonian of which I
have killed billions
that was for Krypton the attacks on the
fleet are weakening them I could feel
them losing steam as we fought good
should make it easier to cut him off
from the beta's
[Music]
this is Batman
Brainiac is down they disrupt her work
all the Vedas are shutting down we did
it now we find Cara what's happening
brainiacs mind is the ship's CPU
apparently he didn't come back
[Music]
if we crash all the cities preserve
Concord destroyed
clock wait you said yourself the ship is
controlled by pure thought this can kill
you
sounds like a job for me
[Music]
[Music]
created by Pastor put the ship on
autopilot right my ship you will not
destroy
request
[Music]
you will regret that
you are persistent but primitive
theatrics cannot save you
like you said I'm persistent
we need to get you out of there not yes
the city's
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you're okay I thought it was too late
but I can feel the heartbeat of Atlantis
brainiacs work is undone not all odd I
couldn't save everyone some cities are
still trapped in the collection others
were lost wiped from the ship's memory
metropolis Coast City but we can still
save them right Carol my family I'm
sorry how first Krypton now earth no
other world should suffer this
Clark no
even if I agreed that he should die who
can't we need him alive to save the rest
of our cities no we don't but more time
cyborgs help a ship will obey me or we
could lose more cities Bruce is right we
can't be sure what we can be sure of is
that Brainiac puts everyone else at risk
this is no different than Joker if you
killed him
we might get was never that simple Diana
yes it is Bruce metropolis and Coast
City are gone how many more innocent
people die before you accept that son
lives need to be taken my powers how did
you go with kryptonite courtesy of
firestorm get up towel
stay down enough exposure and you'll be
deep powered permanently this madness
has to end Bruce